well joining me now is the veteran LGBT
activist and Human Rights Campaign a bit
attachable political journalist Ava
Santina and by the best-selling author
conservative commentator Douglas Murray
well Douglas you're safely over there in
the United States so let me start with
you before the fun starts here
um this stuff reads like a joke but it's
really not funny when you get into the
weeds of it this is Limitless
self-identity Don bonkers
yeah it's um the very stupid results of
a very stupid idea ideology being rolled
out by very stupid people uh basically
everything has come unstuck in recent
years by the ever expanding alphabet
acronym people where the fight for gay
rights and minority sexual rights turned
into this demand this claim that there
was no such thing as biological sex as
uh Peter tatchell and others well know
the argument for gay rights was one by
saying we just like the rest of you it
was also one by saying you know we just
want to Live and Let Live yet the gender
ideologues have done something totally
different they've said you don't have
the right to have your own say in this
we are right and you have to agree with
us they say we're here and instead of
saying we're here we're queer with them
and just get used to it it's we're here
and as a result biological reality does
doesn't exist well clearly this very
very idiotic ideology is causing Havoc
just today Pierce as another a tape from
a school in Scotland where some poor boy
is having to explain to his teacher
there's only two biological Sexes and
that the gender woo-woo stuff is
nonsense and yet again it's the student
having to educate the teacher because
the teacher has been indoctrinated into
stupidity due to the gender ideologues
okay either you're laughing why it's
just quite amusing really I mean we're
talking about children that are 12 and
13 I mean when I was at school I had a
girl who identified as a horse but not
in this sort of like problematic way
that we're now labeling it she didn't
actually think she was a horse she was
just quite strange and walked around and
you know but nobody in the school then
no teachers would have tolerated that in
the way that this is now having to be
told no teacher would have tolerated
bullying of that child and that's what
this teacher in Sussex has done they've
said it's not acceptable for boys in
that class to take the Mickey out of
someone who's obviously clearly just a
child and they're exploring their
imagination he says they're a cat yes
yes but appears they're 12. and he's
actually interfering with the lessons by
talking in cat language including
meowing and if people don't go along
with this refusing to cooperate yeah
that is not just having a bit of fun
being a cat that is actually assuming
the identity of an animal that this
person is not yeah and then insisting
everybody else conform to it that is mad
that's not what's happening what's
happening is there's a child who's
slightly more imaginative than their
peers and they are acting out this sort
of fallacy and that's fine but to make
it about trans or to this is where it
gets dangerous okay the telegraph oh
it's very damaging to translate I agree
right okay I agree with that reason it's
most damaging the telegraph I've been
reporting this is up 400 in the last
couple of years then reporting trans
issues I don't understand why they've
got this weird obsession with going in
let me explain why let me explain why oh
it's quite good let me explain why when
you have in women's sport six foot four
inch biological males destroying
biological females at Elite Sport level
in swimming pools on race tracks in
other sports that's when it becomes a
full frontal assault on women's rights
to fairness and equality and when you
include them going into dressing rooms
and so on and mixing with biological
females then there's a safety issue when
you have as we had in Scotland a male
rapist identifying at his trial as a
woman to get put into a woman's prison
and being sent there by the female boss
of Scotland at the time who's now
obviously in her own troubles that is
why this is this is happening kids are
watching all this stuff and as kids do
they want a piece of the action no peers
don't be ridiculous there is nothing
there's no similarity between a child
wanting to be a cat when they're 12
years old and someone competing in the
Olympics oh there is there is Peterson
you and I have had a lot of civilized
conversations about all this right and I
want to continue that I don't think that
the trans Community gets helped At All
by any of this right but I don't think
it's the media obsessing I think what
you're seeing is as the trans Community
get ever more active and populous if you
like for one of a better phrase and
their activists get more aggressive when
they go to battle on things like women's
sport they're losing everyone and
they're piling mockery onto the trans
community
if we can go back to the telegraph
article yeah it's quite mischievous out
of the I don't know million or more
pupils in our schools they come up with
five examples five examples out of a
million now that's wrong I I agree it's
wrong but as Ava says the kids are just
acting up fantasies when I was a little
kid I wanted to be Robin Hood but that's
fine that's fine but still the schools
should not be tolerated a teacher should
not be saying if you don't but if you
believe there are that women have
vaginas and men have penises you have to
leave the school that is complete
nonsense right in this particular case
the telegraph site of this handful of
examples they were by teachers
individual teachers they were not school
policy and at least one case the school
disowned the teacher and the policy and
said that it wouldn't happen but what
about this case in Rye College well yeah
I'm sure there are some examples of
excesses but on the basis of those
exceptions you can't make a generalized
attack upon the school system and
suggest that all our kids are being
propagandized in this way because it's
simply when you hear that teacher I
think to bring uh Douglas back in when
you hear that teacher there's clear
evidence of what we've all been fearing
has been going on which is a teacher
caught on tape literally spewing
nonsensical gender ideology propaganda
but one teacher yes
one teacher caught on take right there'd
be many other instances of this being
reported but no one's actually had it on
tape it's a bit like I would liken it to
the party Gate scandal when we finally
got a video of the people having what
was clearly a party there have been lots
of rumors about it so now we have a
teacher clearly on tape doing this but
it's not official school policy
still to my knowledge she is still
working at that school Douglas if I may
a festival Ava rather
um unfortunately misspoke earlier when
she said that the school girl in
question was acting out of fallacy I
think you meant a fantasy but actually
she is acting out of fallacies a fallacy
but you know
do you know what's fascinating which has
been propagated a fallacy which has been
propagated by gender ideologues and is
doing profound damage to gay people
among others in our society as well as
women
explain very quickly why I can't quite
hear you I can hear you muttering
something let me quickly explain why a
poll that just got published in the
United States showed that among the
general population support for gay
marriage has been starting to decline in
the last year why is that it's because
the arguments that actually brought
about liberal rights for all minorities
in last few decades have started to get
turned on their head and turned against
people what is the source of that it is
the gender ideology movement what is the
tripwire for the general public it is
children it is people learning that
their children are being taught
nonsensical things it is being seen by
The Wider public most of whom are
heterosexual and don't need to identify
as CIS or anything else it is being seen
from that Vantage Point as the lgbtqia
plus movement losing control of itself
and so a backlash is starting and the
backlash is coming because people are
lying to children and are using children
for medical experiments there's nothing
funny about that there's nothing that
should cause levity in that it should be
treated by adults seriously okay so
Douglas it's really important actually
all of that point that you've just
brought up it's very on brand for you
because you know you like to stoke fear
you've actually made a career out of it
you know I'll take you back to your book
The Strange death of Europe and you made
a big fright you know you've frightened
the entire public about your thoughts on
Europe and we ended up in brexit you
weren't the sole contributed to that but
you were a big mistake
this
issue when you're talking about lgbtq
what you've just done there is basically
say that the whole of America who have
historically had a problem with gay
marriage are now turning on it because a
couple of children in a classroom in
Sussex want to be a cat if you can't see
the Ridiculousness in that argument I
can't help you no the bigger issues
there is no such thing as gender
ideology we all have gender identities
you identify as a man and I fully
respect you well no no hang on I don't
identify as a man I was born a
biological yes that's where this whole
thing is
I'll bring it back in though as you want
to say that's where the whole debate
goes wrong you were born a biological
male you were born a biological female
Douglas biological male this is just a
fact right no once you start saying
there are hundreds of genders and you
can identify as anything you want you're
going to end up with kids at school
going I'm a horse and you've got to
treat me like a horse here's just
confusing two things sex and gender I'm
not I say I've been completed biological
sex is one thing which I totally accept
and so do 99 of the people in the LGBT
plus Community gender is something
different gender identity is how you see
yourself and do you believe do you
believe it's Limitless no I don't
believe it's limits what's the limit
well there was basically male and female
intersex but there are people who have
different gender identity but how many
genders are there well I I there is no
fixed number so what's the limit I don't
see a particular limit there's no limit
so when you said there was no you said
there is a limit now you admit There's
No Limit sorry
well there is male and female is there a
limit or not identity no that's that's
sex but on agenda is there a limit to
number of genders well there are some
people who are asexual that's an
identity there are so the BBC the BBC
has put in education videos there are a
hundred plus genders well I don't agree
with that I don't agree with so what is
the limit what's the number well
I'm not going to specify a particular
number but it's very small where do you
drop where do you draw the line well I
draw the line based on science and
evidence and we know that there is a
thing called intersex where people are
born with a mixture of both that is
literally what it says that's what it
says that is intersex yeah people are
born with with chromosomes from both
right that is a medical condition that's
inarguable right we're talking about
gender but we're done with trans
identity is also a biological factor but
once I've rooted and limited in brain
structures and Pros understand it but
what's the science shows but once you
get into 100 genders people yeah we're
actually bathing 100 well actually the
BBC has taught kids this is back to
Douglas's point about you know affecting
the brains of impressionable young kids
I don't agree with that I don't agree
with the BBC the plus genders okay
Douglas uh very quickly I I don't know
Ava anything about your career
um I don't know if you have one but you
did try to imply that you knew something
about mine and you just showed you know
nothing about it because actually my
2017 best seller the strange death of
Europe was not about the EU so you
should learn at some point to read more
than the title it was about your
commenting
but let me let me very quickly
how rude is it quickly very quickly
ideas
you've both got wonderful careers or you
wouldn't be on Piers Morgan uncensored
Before I Let You Go Peter though I want
a quick reaction Elton John today
reacted to the Phillip Schofield Scandal
and said that he believed uh it was
totally homophobic that if it had been a
man having a relationship at work with a
20 year old woman there would be no
Scandal what's your response to that I
think there's a whiff of homophobia I
wouldn't say total homophobia there's a
whiff because we know that when big
celebrities like Leonardo DiCaprio
um uh Peter Stringfellow uh Elvis
Presley and so on when they had
relationships with young women much much
younger there was tutting but there
wasn't the kind of witch hunting
atmosphere that Philip Schofield has
experienced now saying that as someone
who says that you know his own private
life should be his own private life
unless he's harmed someone else or
committed a criminal offense otherwise
it's for him you know 40 of all
marriages used to begin at the workplace
and historically with a a man in a
higher position at work that's how
people used to meet and fall in love it
would be the boss the second Trends on
that's not going to happen anymore is it
I mean with the Scofield template now is
you cannot actually really have any
relationships at work and my only
response to that would be okay how are
people going to meet their Partners For
Life actually it's an interesting
question socially if 40 of marriages
began at work and work relationships
become taboo
gen Z now it's all online we don't talk
to each other well there you go there
you go the only thing we should be
concerned about what was a crime
committed was anyone harmed we don't
have any evidence of either in the case
of no we don't at the moment unless
unless the the other man concerned comes
out and contradicts Philips Global story
there is no crime until then the man is
innocent yeah until proven guilt I don't
disagree Peter we reach a point of a
grip always a good place to end Ava
congratulations on your stunning career
which has brought you to the desk of
beers Morgan uncensored Douglas always a
joy over there in New York great to see
you